I'm drew Kirkpatrick and in the
educational technology group here and
I'm gonna run through everybody
introduce everybody first in the order
that they are in the program and then
we'll actually have talking so first
we're going to hear from Leslie Harkema
an assistant professor of Spanish and
director of undergraduate studies for
Spanish our first book Spanish modernism
and the poetics of youth from me go down
a mano the to law in the Torah examine
the little studied relationship between
the renowned essayist novelist and poet
Miguel de Unamuno and several Spanish
writers associated with the so called
generation of 1927 focusing on youth is
a central concept in their aesthetic
thought and self fashioning which seems
I could be useful for teaching
undergraduates
Lesley's courses have included
contemporary issues into Iberian and
Latin American Studies the many faces of
Miguel de Unamuno which is the first
time I had the pleasure of working with
her science and religion and Spanish
literature from 1885 to 1915 and
introduction to the cultures of Spain so
I'll talk about thinking through
historical narratives and chronologies
in this last class as well as the
intellectual collaboration of creating a
website and of course on Miguel de
Unamuno
to my left Catherine's Lansky holds a
joint appointment is lecturer in the
Department of Near Eastern languages and
civilizations and in the humanities
Catherine teaches starry studies ancient
Mesopotamia at the intersections of
sources and approaches looking in
particular at questions of monumentality
sacred and secular Authority and the
ancient transmission and reception of
literary historical religious and visual
traditions which we fast-forward to the
very very modern transmission of those
things and in addition to her teaching
in the directed Studies program for
which she was also the course
coordinator in history politics
she teaches Mesopotamian and ancient
Near Eastern literature history religion
law and justice visual arts and ancient
languages recent course offerings
include the hero in the ancient Near
East discovering and reception of
ancient Egypt and Mesopotamia with John
Darnielle reimagining the ancient Near
East and translating the hero with
Korean passive classics anita lassen is
associate curator of the yale babylonian
collection trained in the archaeology
history and art history
the ancient Near East her research areas
the social and economic history of
Mesopotamian Anatolia in the second
millennium BCE and in particular
elliptic studies and ancient textiles
her approach is interdisciplinary and
she works with visual culture
archaeological material and written
sources among her teaching at Yale has
been visible language the origins of
writing and Mesopotamia in ancient Egypt
and seals and sealing in ancient Near
East among other exhibits she's curated
at the Danish National Museum the
permanent exhibit on Persia and solo
curated exhibits on women in ancient
Mesopotamia and modern Syrian art with
links to the ancient past Katherine and
I need to we'll discuss their spring
2017 course in which they explored the
use of vr for teaching about the ancient
Near East all the way over on the right
my right sorry Brett Smith is a Helmsley
postdoctoral teaching scholar in the
department of mathematics
he's also the assistant coordinator of
yellows flipped classroom integral
calculus course currently teaching
calculus of functions of one variable
and mathematics in the real world and
his teaching work Brett makes
introductory math more accessible
through peer instruction just in time
short response questions and small group
activities in class together with Jim
Rolf he created a video game called cart
as a way of helping students better
understand function properties Brett
will talk about the calculus class and
how they've changed and diversify the
way its students have access to and take
action with the course ideas and finally
to my right again Tracy Addie who is our
associate director of faculty teaching
initiatives here who comes to us with a
PhD in science education from North
Carolina State University which I have
to mention cuz I'm a Tar Heels fan and
that's a problem prior to arriving at
the center she taught undergraduate
biology for ten years and managed the
assessment programs at the Yale School
of Medicine's teaching and learning
center currently she works in
partnership with faculty and departments
on their teaching initiatives she's also
a board member of the New England
faculty development course consortium
and in her clearly copious spare time
enjoys writing undergraduate science
cases in conducting an educational
research today she'll describe
experiment experiences implementing game
based learning with undergraduate and
advanced high school students and the
relevant outcomes and so first we'll
hear from Leslie
I can drive her you can maybe if we
switch I can just click through I sex
good afternoon everyone I was asked to
speak for just a few minutes so I'll try
to be brief I want to bring two examples
of how I've used digital technology in
my upper level language Spanish culture
and literature classes so I'm aware that
my colleagues in the actual language
program are doing fantastic things using
technology to improve interactions with
students who are language learners I
continue to work with language learners
but I'm talking with them about
literature and about culture so these
are a couple of ways that I've used time
line the program time line and then
simply the the course press website
development that we have available to us
you know to increase student
collaboration in my classes and and to
foment critical thinking so that mmm
learning and thinking about a foreign
culture in a different language is
something that students can really do in
an interactive way where they can
intervene and think about producing new
knowledge even in an intellectual
tradition that is foreign to them so and
this first example is from the course
website that my students in my
introduction to the cultures of Spain
course developed last year and this was
a course that was supported by the
association teaching program here at the
CTL and one of our projects the graduate
student and I who the graduate student
who helped me redesign this course was
to change the format for this course
this is a course that's been taught in
the Spanish Department in the Spanish
program for quite a while
and always in a very chronological
moving from the Middle Ages to
contemporary Spain in one semester
sort of approach we decided to opt for a
topical approach to the course focusing
on Spain's relationships with immigrant
populations Spain's relationships with
Europe and Spain's relation
with Latin America in order to maintain
a certain sense of chronology we use
this program timeline to give students a
reference point as we move through
various topics and really jumped around
different time periods looking at each
different theme so we set up this
timeline that students had available to
them from the beginning of this semester
and the students populated it over the
course of the term so for example one of
the key reference points for this course
is the Year 1492 a very important year
if you can think of important things
that happened Columbus landed in the
quote/unquote new worlds but there were
also a number of other events that are
pivotal for an understanding of Spanish
culture the Spaniards completed the
reconquest of Spain defeating the
Kingdom of Granada the first grammar of
the Spanish language was published and
it was also the year of the expulsion of
the Jews so right there we have a lot of
different topics that really that day
came up in every piece of the class so
to have this date as a point of
departure students populated the course
in a variety of ways they talked about
the contact with the new world they
talked about different literary figures
working in Spain in the centuries
following the 1492 date and they also
brought in information about important
cultural figures people who were of
interest to them one ala Luca figure a
member of the royal family was believed
to have gone mad I'm looking for one in
particular okay and one intervention
from
student who brought in the writings of
Bartolome de las casas who wrote about
the defense of indigenous peoples in the
Americas so this timeline worked as a
nexus for different points of our
conversation too to coincide in one
further example at the end of the
semester we watched a documentary on
Ecuadorian immigrants in Spain and that
history had a long it was a documentary
based in 21st century Spain but it based
itself on the story of a virgin
mythological an appearance of the
version in Ecuador so we were able to
locate that event on the map as well the
other example that I brought today is
from a course that I teach on Miguel de
Unamuno
a figure very well known in Spain and in
Spanish culture but one who's often
studied from a very limited perspective
within the United States he's known for
a couple of canonical works that
students often read in introductory
classes so in my own research I worked
to improve knowledge of different parts
of his his production especially I'm
interested in his poetry and his role in
Spanish history so the quartet of course
I teach Unamuno focuses on his multiple
phases and the first time that I taught
it I had students get involved in this
project of creating a website together
in which we have different pages devoted
to the different phases of this thinker
and the students populated again
populated the website with their own
research it was an opportunity for them
also to think about translation as this
website we actually had a launch at the
end of the semester and we made it
public so it was a great opportunity for
students to think about how they were
interacting with an intial intellectual
tradition that exists in Spain and we
looked at Wikipedia and lifted different
comments about about this figure both in
Spanish and in English
and they were able to insert their own
voices into into that tradition and then
also think about translating for an
audience here in the US who might not
read or speak Spanish so those are just
two examples and let pass the mic on
thank you um I'm Katherine slansky
and I'm here because of a kind of
experiment that we did in collaboration
with the CTL in the spring it was in
conjunction with a course that I've
taught for many years at Yale the hero
in the ancient Near East its cross
listed in nearest in languages and
civilizations and I see many of my
friends from the department here and
also in humanities and also in classical
civilizations it is a very you could
tell by all this cross listings it is
inherently interdisciplinary and what
makes it interdisciplinary is that I'm
I'm using a lot of visual material
together with primary texts in
translation and trying to create as rich
and as an experience as possible for the
students who take the course it's it's
hard to teach a course that is to teach
material that is so distant in time and
place and experience from our own and if
you're thinking about your own
experience perhaps studying ancient
Mesopotamia you're thinking Hammurabi in
fifth grade social studies and I can see
already your eyes are beginning to glaze
over so the more sort of energized I can
make this material more relevant I can
make it the better and in the context of
teaching in the humanities what we're
trying to do or one of the things we're
always trying to do is to show how study
of any aspect of culture can serve as a
vehicle for understanding our own
experiences in our own culture so this
course that I teach on the hero in the
ancient Near East it already has a kind
of hook for a lot of students
the I do the hero that's kind of sexy
and I I get a lot of athletes in this
class which is fabulous they are they're
wonderful students they are very
organized they're very on top of things
and they maybe even in spite of
themselves start to see the way we view
heroes and our own society and culture
and by looking at heroes in this ancient
society and culture so that's sort of
the objective of the course but there's
there's real serious things that happen
over the course of the semester we talk
about values and how what a society
values is projected or filtered through
these heroic figures that society holds
up and we do that kind of critically and
we start actually the conversation about
who are our heroes in twenty thousand
seventeen in the United States of
America and that leads to a very almost
uncomfortable conversation at times but
that's a great way to get this
conversation rolling and then we talk
about one of the one of the themes that
we have that goes across the whole
semester our ideas about Authority how
authority is established how authority
can be projected particularly political
authority and we start to talk about
ideology and how that is conveyed in
both verbal and visual expressions the
course is structured chronologically
there's there's a lot of reasons for
that but what I'm getting to what what I
think we're going to show you in a
minute
is a video made by Yale news that that
actually came out last week that
showcases a module a virtual reality
module that my students were able to use
as part of a one of our class units so
by the time we get from the dawn of
civilization
fifth grade social studies cradle of
civilization first cities invention of
writing dot Code of Hammurabi dot we get
up to the Assyrian Empire and now we're
talking about layers and layers of
tradition that are encoded into the
figure of the Assyrian King and I had an
a unit already in place for an exercise
already in place for this week's unit
that we would go over to the Yale art
gallery where there are some sculptured
reliefs from one of the palaces of these
great Assyrian Kings on display but my
colleague in the Babylonian collection
where I bring the students often and we
were able to look at artifacts and
handle them and touch them suggested
that you know there's this virtual
reality thing out there where you can
actually experience a room within one of
these Assyrian palaces so then I
redesigned the assignment to incorporate
a visit here to the CTL where the
students put on the headgear and you'll
see this in the video and actually
entered the palace virtually and I had
them think about some questions
beforehand what to look for what to
think about and their assignment at the
end was to write a letter as if they
were a visitor to this palace either a
foreign hostage or an ambassador or one
of the Kings own provincial
administrators who had come for an
audience with the king and then to write
a letter back home about that experience
and what did it felt like and what they
experienced so are we ready to do that
to Palace and you're thinking what
wouldn't it be ideal if there was a way
that they could immerse them and that we
lost Jin city of new militants used
military vehicles to destroy at least
part of the archaeological site groups
destruction of an ancient city and this
crater is all that remains of the
ancient Assyrian city of Nimrod it's
just unbelievable the destruction and
how they're targeting pre-islamic era
cultural heritage it is part of our
human past and that that element that
part of our past is irretrievably lost
we can do the best that we can to teach
our own students about this past but
these students would never be able to
visit that palace that was another
reason for choosing this particular
model to introduce the students first
the VR is the next best thing
[Music]
the course is a introduction to ancient
Near Eastern culture when we get to the
Assyrian Kings now we can talk about one
of their great cultural expressions
which are these monumental palaces they
entered a throne room in a palace and
the palace was called the northwest
Palace and it was built by an Assyrian
ruler called as renacer pal so these
were meant to be a projection of the
might of the Empire and the might of the
King
they're like mountains they're so big
and you can't comprehend that human
beings created this so the way that
we're taught with images and little
objects you never understand you know
what is the scale of these things what
does it feel like to be in the palace
and what's the grandeur of such a palace
then you're thinking what wouldn't it be
ideal if there was a way that they could
immerse them in that particular
environment we decided maybe we can
start using we are as a possible
technology to health of that so virtual
reality is not really established as a
viable instructional tool yet you know
we're in unknown territory well weird ah
that's so crazy it is not about the
technology it is all about how we use
the technology to impact education and
just help it make a better experience
depicted in the Syrian art is having
poles or Alliance bodies it was a lot
more effective as a teaching tool than I
had expected there's a reconstruction of
partial of one of these rooms at the
Metropolitan Museum of Art and I take
students there as well but it's nothing
like the dizzying sensation of stepping
into the throne room in this virtual
reality it was really amazing to to go
into 2dr and get that sense of space you
have these goosebumps
going and you have the chills because
the light
the sounds and everything is absolutely
like you are in that and Madison
environment the ceiling is so high you
have to turn your head to look up at it
it's a physical sensation of stepping
into a really large space that is so
large it's disorienting the highest
ceilings but I don't understand how you
paint that high and you're living in
like I'm even know 4000 BC there's no
substitute for the real thing but what
the VR does in combination with the real
art is set it into its architectural
context in a way that is very difficult
for for anyone to do with slides there
are some constants and some almost
incomprehensible differences but
understanding the human past and objects
that were created in the past I think it
tells us something about what what did
you know the human condition what it is
to be a human so what what happened
when we were when we were doing this
exercise this classroom assignment I
hadn't been thinking so much about the
the way that this video was going to
turn out that Yale News did that
happened all after the fact but what
happened in the classroom was that that
we were able to pick up on a theme of of
cultural stewardship and our sort of
interaction and treatment of cultural
heritage that we could experience and we
had you know we had talked in our inner
class about what was going on currently
in Iraq and you know can what's
happening with this with these artworks
that we had been studying now that video
makes it very dramatic kind of news
newsy thing which wasn't what we were
doing so much in the classroom but
having gone through the the VR
experience the students did come back
with a kind of ownership that they
hadn't had before
and I'm I guess we'll have time to talk
about other hi I'm Brett I'm gonna talk
about our use of technology in a
coordinated calculus course so we have
kind of a unique challenge in teaching
calculus to that we have many sections
taught by different instructors all
happening at the same time and all
giving the same sort of summative
assessments and calculus is a different
difficult topic to teach but it's also
really foundational for lots of
different STEM disciplines and it's
really an entry point into many
different departments so it's it's a
really important important that we we
get some things right and so I took over
a flipped model where we the flipped
course was set up by Jim Rolf where we
really were thinking about sort of three
phases of how we're helping the students
learn one what's happening before class
to what's happening in class and then
three what's happening after class and
how can we get the most out of those
three phases and so what we what we have
happening before classes we have content
delivery where we're having students
watch videos that were primarily created
by Jim Rolf and then we have online
quizzes that are paired with the content
in the videos where the students get
some feedback in terms of how well they
understood what they just sort of were
exposed to but also that the instructor
gets information about how well the
students understood that first exposure
so we get some statistics about how the
class is doing
and we also get a free response question
where the students tell us what it was
that they found really difficult or
really interesting about what they just
been exposed to so all of that happens
before we get to see them
then we can respond to that and what are
the things that we do in class and in
class like I said we have many different
sections which means many different
instructors and people have freedom to
do what they'd like during that time I
use clickers and slides which is pretty
unusual for a math course that amount of
Technology but I find the slides are
really useful because they allow me to
ask them a lot of questions and this is
something that I'm freed up to do
because I don't have to deliver
definitions and theorems that they've
already been exposed to but it also
affects sort of the way I think about
designing questions and rather than just
giving them some exercise they might see
in a book I've got to predict what kind
of answers they're going to want to give
to a question and so I can really target
those misconceptions with
multiple-choice questions and then
there's also kind of a gimmick aspect of
the clicker where I force them to
respond I get to tell them the
distribution of who thinks what problem
is correct and then I get to tell them
okay now talk to somebody and see if you
want to change your choice and the
response you get out of students just
because they know that they're
responsible for clicking something even
though I don't know who's clicking what
or you know there's no accountability
they they feel that it's time for them
to talk to their partner and actually
interact which you know I've tried to do
some other things without clickers and
and it's just it just is more effective
and for whatever reason that that
technology is really helpful for that
purpose and then the last thing
I've added to this course is what's
happening as students prepare for their
exams I implemented a video project
where we post old exams online and I
have the students create video solutions
with partners so they're really short
only like maybe one part of question on
an exam what they're providing a
three-minute response sort of giving
their their their thought process and
going through an exam problem and so
this helps them prepare but it then can
live on as a resource for the class as
they prepare for later exams so we post
this to a kind of communal page on
canvas we use the Panopto software that
links in but also I like the idea that
these videos can live as a resource for
students in future semesters and so to
bring in this idea that you're part of a
much bigger community learning calculus
and you're part of you know the cohort
that learned last semester and the
semester before that and so because you
know we have these little sections all
teaching thinking about how the
technology can then build a larger
community that's sort of how I've been
thinking about that part so that's
that's what we do before in an after
class and then you know part of this is
we're training graduate students to be
teaching too so giving them this
exposure to all these things we think is
really important so they can take what
they like and form their own opinions on
how how useful this stuff is okay hello
everybody my name is Tracy a D and as
Tripp mentioned before I work in the
center now but I used to teach biology
so one of the things that I really like
to do in my spare time is to write case
studies which are basically stories that
help students apply information they
learn in class in an engaging way so
today I want to talk about an activity
that I cream
and that hope to send for publication
soon it is a case study that's called
the Ebola Wars mission immune evasion so
it gets into the immune system because
that's a topic that I found that
students had a lot of trouble with so I
was trying to think what is a creative
way to teach this topic to students this
particular case study it integrates a
game and I'll show you that game in a
little bit that game actually has been
used we've implemented this in the
classroom twice so I'll be able to talk
a little bit about the outcomes so the
case has been developed and with gaming
company called cat Lilly games they've
been phenomenal and trying to think
about how can we use gaming in science
and use it in an educational way and so
why did I do this well I wanted to see
first off like I mentioned immunology
how can we cover it in an interesting
way and then second off how can we
engage students in learning science in
any way and I think I mentioned earlier
was experimenting I was definitely
thinking of experimenting when I was
creating this so we implemented the game
twice the lesson twice one was once was
at the undergraduate level and another
one with our Yale young global scholars
students which are high achieving high
school students who come in the summer
with the young young global scholars we
were able to do a study to actually look
at some of the impacts of the game so if
you see me present on this before which
some some a few people have I can
actually give a little few new things
now because now I have some of the
results of the study I can't go into all
the details of the study we're still
analyzing the data but I can bring out a
few things so one thing that was really
great to see when students completed the
activity is that I looked at like what
were their perceptions of the activity
in general do they like it at cetera so
there was a few questions that really
directed that that were directed at this
and the first one was the boulevard case
study activity increased my
understanding of the session material so
the students range from six to six point
three out of seven on that so that's
pretty high so we were happy about that
another question asked I'm confident in
my understanding of the material
presented during today's Ebola virus
case study about five point two to five
point seven was
range out of seven we also looked at so
not only their understanding we also
looked at their their preferences too
for and whether or not not they had fun
so a question asked
I had fun during today's Ebola virus
case study it was around five point six
to five point eight out of seven for the
different groups in the study and I
would prefer to take a class that
includes this Ebola virus group study
similar about five five point five so
it's very pleased to see that students
really enjoyed the game and they thought
they perceived at least that it enhanced
their understanding we also did a little
study to look at well were they actually
learning right so you can do games and
you can do you know these interventions
but were they actually learning so we
did actually like a pre survey in a post
survey to look at their knowledge and to
see if they actually had gains and we
had different groups I'm not gonna go in
the complexity of the study but some of
the groups did games some of them didn't
etc but overall they all had pretty good
normal normalized learning gains which
is like how much did they actually learn
versus the maximal possible learning
that could have had so they range from
like point forward of 0.5 so really
happy about this the the case seemed to
go pretty well and it kind of exceeded
my expectations and there's a neat way
to think about how to use gaming in the
classroom so I did want to show a video
that I took of me actually playing the
game I had to take this multiple times
because I didn't always win every time
so that's good so it's a challenging
game but I edited all that out of course
so here's hopefully a little clip and I
think it was on the desktop as a
download
this is the game operation Ebola in
development by cat Lilly games the goal
of the game is for the player a cell
infected with the Ebola virus to evade
the immune response and infect more
cells the first time a player plays the
game they can run through the
introductory material describing the
basic science highlighted in a game
another feature of the game is that they
can switch the background color in the
case of colorblindness players can also
go directly to the game but will first
need to manipulate the genome of the
virus in their desired way this affects
their gameplay and their ability to
bathe the immune response
in the first part of the game the virus
has infected a cell and enter the
bloodstream the goal is to dodge various
barriers also the player can release the
viral particles by pressing a as well so
that will serve to infect other cells
after this point if they are successful
they are confronted with various cells
of the immune system the first being
macrophage cells which they try to
infect the more cells they in fact the
more their score increases if they come
in contact with a macrophage or other
defense mechanism their health score
will decrease
so we'll try to infect these macrophage
cells as best as we can by releasing
Ebola viruses and try not to give in
contact with any of them now we'll start
to see these dendritic cells come into
play will affect those as well so we'll
see macrophages and dendritic cells
now this is the point where this
antibody storm comes into play and and
you can see my health score is rapidly
decreasing over time and my game is over
so these are the essentials of the game
the students have really enjoyed playing
it and we really look forward to it
further being used in the classroom so
that's just an overview of the game but
it does a company a very scaffolded case
study where they go through various
parts and they play this during one part
of that case just so they have some
perspective thank you great thank you
all we're gonna take questions from the
audience in just a moment but I'm gonna
take chair privilege here and start and
I'm gonna do my Phil Donahue bit which
just dated me incredibly so one thing I
wanted to ask everybody is that I was
assumed technology will fail I've been
working with technology for a long time
and it always failed sooner or later and
that can be catastrophic or it can just
be running up against the limits of what
you want to do what the students want to
do so I was hoping maybe people could
talk just a little bit about where you
found limits where it sort of didn't
work for you and and what you learn from
that maybe how you turned that into a
teachable moment or whether it just was
ugly and didn't go well so I don't start
down there
so we had higher expectations for the
resolution of the imagery in the model
that we used we got the VR model from a
private company that developed it for us
and we would have liked to seen higher
resolution we are hoping to solve that
problem going forward by building our
own 3d models virtual reality models the
model is also only developed for one
specific room made an entire Palace and
it would have been nice for the students
to have been able to walk from the outer
courtyard and then into the throne room
and not just being in confined in one
one single room another thing is that
only one student at a time could enter
the VR model and it would have been
great for a whole group of students to
be able to be present in the model at
one time and also a teacher could be
ideally that's something social VR is is
another component that I think would be
really amazing going forward you could
even imagine having a teacher in London
who is meeting with a group of students
that are at Yale and then giving a talk
about their specific knowledge about
whichever architecture their standing in
so those are some of their the
limitations said that we found with the
with the VR so just as a font that's
interesting so when so as we saw in the
video student goes in in to the palace
how how did you have those conversations
with them it had to be then they came
out and related their impressions to you
since you couldn't see how they were
going through the model okay so
Catherine had given them specific and a
specific assignment in there the company
that we worked with on developing and
using the model modified certain parts
of the model to light up in green so
that you could approach a specific
object or a specific place in the model
and then that would be activated either
with images or text or speech then as
the students approached an object or
turned their heads to look at an object
that might open up another visual plant
panel that would show it in detail or
black and white and higher con
or I think even in an in an
archaeological excavation when they were
first being discovered and then there
would be a voiceover there would be so
spoken text that would describe what
they were looking at for me I think one
of the challenges of using time line was
that the technology didn't wasn't as
complex as I was hoping it would be so I
had initially started out thinking that
we would be able to stratify different
moments according to relations to the
art history development of cultural
movements versus politics versus
different ways that we might kind of
cross create connections across time and
even adjust that to meet certain a
certain students research interests and
that really timeline pretty much works
it was more even more chronological than
than I wanted it to be so so it was
difficult sometimes to create those sort
of interventions to really have students
think about resisting a received notion
of history or chronology but we were
able to have those conversations in
class and it was certainly a useful tool
in in drying out those sorts of
connections and at least noticing
coincidences between what was going on
in Latin America and on the Iberian
Peninsula at a given time um I think for
mine there are like different layers of
challenges along the way and we're
almost done with this so it's still
going I guess but one of them is like
just conceptualizing how do you put this
in a game I think that whole process of
working with the company and making it
educational was a big deal and it took a
lot it takes a lot of effort to actually
think about that and to have it be
accurate like the science
okay as I was saying so the one you know
creative aspect of like thinking about
technology and using it for learning you
know I think I also ties in someone with
like VR and things like that like how
can we make this an educational
experience so that came into play and
then also just like practical things
like for example our game
it can't be played on a cell phone it
has to be played on a laptop because of
a software that's used so thinking of
those types of things and then you have
to have your students bring the laptop
to class and then monitor them make sure
they get on and things like that so I
think those were the ones that I faced
most actually so much of the technology
has worked well I've been really happy
but one thing we've run into is so much
of our course is hosted online that
we're dependent on sort of the
capability of the program where I work
so in fact so most of our course was
hosted on one platform but that platform
sort of changed directions in terms of
the types of content they wanted to be
hosting so we had to transition to
everything being hosted on canvas which
luckily we had great support from the
CTL for that all work but you sort of
have to be sort of proactive and focused
on the future of the things that you
want to do in the future of the
capabilities of the the technology are
working with so that that's been kind of
a challenge so I think we can turn to
the audience now and see if there's any
questions out here don't be shy
I want to ask I think it's a Tracy you
know in the game I teach a Czech
language and Czech language is very
complex in terms of morphology for
instance a student who lived in Prague
for 3 months even to a store and said C
- chica - chica is a bag and it's a is
Iwan but he put the wrong case instead
of saying it's it - go and the person
didn't understand him at all and it
happened several time so obviously
students struggle it's the endings and I
think I have been thinking very often
it'll be really fun for them to make it
instead of like a game like you had
something very similar you know in order
to put the right ending it lets you fart
at you let's say complete the sentence
and it will be also nice to have some
kind of a background how would I
approach this who would help me that
said how I mean I can compose a you know
little of text and then leave the
endings off and the students would be
you know completing it but you know I
don't know how to go about it home to
approach so and I think it would be
tremendously helpful because I've
noticed in the classroom if we if I do
something orally as a game they just
enjoy it but if I don't they just find
it so boring because grammar ultimately
is boring and if they have actually very
hard understanding of these endings you
know because there are so many there's
so many nouns different categories and
there are seven endings for every every
single noun so this would be you know
tremendous help so if someone could help
me I really would appreciate it thank
you yes so are you thinking of more a
digital version or a non digital because
it could go either way
digital version will be the best you
know I sort of like what you had because
you know it's based on these I remember
my son when he was little he used to
this you know press this on it in
whatever you know this Gameboy whatever
it was and so I think that the students
would just enjoy it and especially if
they could have it let's say on their
you know iPods or computers but even
just in the classroom you know I think I
have actually twenty boys taking my
check and you know obviously they are
you know very
the female voice sort of missing that
it's also difficult in a language so I
think they just would absolutely love it
and would enjoy it and would sort of
like compete with each other you know
who is the first because that's sort of
like that competitive spirit so I think
digital would be obviously the best but
I'm willing to you know have anything as
long as as I have something because
there has been so little developed
almost nothing in in check so we're
happy to help you faculty teaching
initiatives just to start thinking about
your ideas for this particular game I
collaborated with a gaming company so
they were the ones that actually helped
to do the programming to create the
actual game and I think did you
collaborate with a company as well sure
yeah I also created a game for to help
students prepare for calculus so yeah we
there's a center for health and learning
games in the medical school so we talked
to people over there about their
experiences and got linked up with a
company called preview labs who does
rapid game design and worked with them
so yeah I mean just talking to different
people and figuring out the best people
to collaborate with yeah hi thanks for
sharing your experiences I just wanted
to ask you guys about cost
considerations when you're pairing with
these companies so I find that if I'm
working with vendors they're often
willing to you know work with you on the
very first maybe module that you want
you just because they wanted to tease
out the relationship but as you start
needing to get more complex um then they
come back to you and say well in order
to do this we need X hours of manpower
and whatnot for us you know or for what
I do a VR probably isn't enough but like
now we're talking about AR and that's
essentially how
which is you know $3,000 per per thing
and it's not even out yet so I just
wanted to know if you guys had navigated
ways to approach these companies about
cost or how you're dealing with that um
I can speak just to my experience um the
company I work with as an educational
company and they were very interested in
thinking about like ways to publish
their games so they're they're not doing
it for free they're doing it because
we're publishing the case and of
research and etc on it so that that's
kind of their primary motivation so I
haven't run into the cost issue but
others can probably attest to the
financial aspects I don't know of it yes
so the our VR model came with a price
tag but it wasn't exorbitant the
expensive but it did come with a price
and they did ask for extra money for any
modifications that we wanted to
introduce I think part of the the reason
for making that investment was that CTL
that there was a huge meeting here at
CTA with all kinds of technical people
who wanted to get and who want to start
developing VR things for Yale and so
they were talking about you know
designing things for 2020 and I was
saying April I I want this unit for
April and so we we bought this I'm
saying we I somebody bought this thing
CTL CTL bought this program that you saw
and and I believe also the license right
so so we can now modify this so so my
colleague who's teaching on a whole a
whole course on Assyrian history this
semester can modify it can add his own
voiceovers and play with it I think I
think part of the reason for the
investment was that the more instructors
the more instructional faculty who make
use of it in collaboration with the
technical people at CTL then they can
start designing things
for more of our classrooms here together
and also this particular model is going
to be used not but just by your class
but also by by other classes in the
future so and I think the company is a
game company right is called learning
sites
it's a massachusetts-based company and
they have worked with Assyrian and Near
Eastern architecture and sites for since
the 80s I think they started but they
specialize in sites all over the
Mediterranean area historical sites and
and one of the pieces that I own a day
brings to this collaboration as her
familiarity with museums around the
world who are increasingly putting very
high quality digital photographs
including kind of 3d imagery making it
available publicly open-source and so we
can now now that we own this Assyrian
throne room that you that you watched we
can incorporate some of those materials
into this program and and really
customize it for different teaching
units among different courses different
faculty across the university
jace you talked about the complexity of
the immune system and how difficult it
was to design this and what point and
it's an experiment at what point did it
become more interesting enough to for
you to invest your time and the money to
make this as opposed to just asking
questions because and obviously and the
second part of the question is when
you're designing the game because of the
complexity of the immune system you just
mentioned there's a million outcomes for
every one of those interactions between
the virus and and the cell or whatever
other components and now how do you
decide how to eliminate and are the
students getting more out of this at
this point than they would if you just
ask them to draw diagram did something
very low-tech those are all really good
questions so I think your first question
was at what point was this like worth it
instead of just explaining it or was it
yeah um I feel like you know this case
we're we're gonna send it off soon for
publication it would be nice to have a
bigger wide sales study of it nationally
implemented to actually you know kind of
give more insight into that um my
motivation for doing it like I like I
told you was I published these anyway in
thinking about engaging students so I
see this as being used in many different
ways and not opposed to like following a
lecture that you know describes some of
the more intricate details and then
going and doing the case afterwards
so um I I mean that's a really good
question you know at what point because
I'm so interested in learner centered
classrooms to me it's well worth it to
have an interactive activity for the
students to engage in the immune system
in this way and then your second
question was can you repeat that again
when you're designing the game with yeah
how do you decide yeah exactly yeah that
was a challenging thing to think about
so in order to do that we thought of the
level of the students and we thought
what would be some of the foundational
material they would cover we've thought
about this in an introductory biology
course what would be some of the
important elements so I think we we used
that as a gauge like what we normally
teach and what will we think are is
important one of the collaborators the
faculty that works with me he he'd
studies you know the studied Ebola virus
etc so he also kind of narrowed down
what were the essential elements that he
would feel are important to know at this
very early level but I feel like it's
difficult because obviously there's much
to include so we try to focus mostly on
what most biology classrooms would talk
about at minimum that's kind of how we
distilled it out but obviously we
there's room for people describing more
outside of the case and talking more in
their classes yes yeah very very true so
that's that back and forth I was telling
you about with the gaming company I
think what we were really challenged
with is we don't want students to form
misconceptions because of the game so
we're trying to like counter all as many
as we can you know and trying to make it
as accurate scientifically as possible
so I agree I think that's a big you know
issue in creating these games as best as
possible in a fun way so you raised a
very valid point all right hi thanks
great presentation from all really
interesting stuff there what I'm
interested in is how we help students
get the most from these distinctive uses
of technology for example our students
come to University have not really been
in a quality field trip and if you're
not careful the student tries to learn
from a field trip I thought it was a
lecture theatre with mud yeah no um I'm
wondering
whether colleagues made any particular
attempts to coach students in terms of
you know in order to learn from a VR a
city in throne room think about things
this but this isn't just a lecture which
is 360 hours of over learning from a
game about viruses it's not just like
having a really fun lecture about
viruses it's something else so I'm
wondering have you engaged in any sort
of coaching of students to help them
create new paradigms in the mind about
how to learn from these kind of
distinctive opportunities the the unit
in my syllabus for for which I was able
to plug in this virtual reality
experience already existed I already had
an assignment for the students to go to
the art gallery and spend some time
studying the sculptures that are there
and and we had we had talked about it in
the in the classroom they had done some
reading I had shown some slides I had
pointed out some specific elements for
them to keep in mind as they went and
encountered these these massive I mean
these monumental stone orthostats what
what the VR enabled me to do was was
take that assignment that I already had
and and tweak it for the larger
architectural context and and I went
over and put the goggles on before I
I sent the students over so that I would
have an understanding of what they were
gonna see and what you saw in the video
I think everyone had the same experience
like whoa it it is dizzying I I couldn't
I couldn't even do the whole thing
because it made me motion sick which I
didn't tell the students about but but
one of them also had that experience so
that I you know that's another kind of
limitation of the technology and and I
don't know what will happen with that
this stuff is progressing every minute
but
what so I asked them you know the
assignment was they to already be
thinking about this image of the king
from two different perspectives we had
we had studied together some of the
Kings own inscriptions which are very
self laudatory and then we had looked at
some passages from the Hebrew Bible that
look at the Assyrian King from a very
different perspective and I had we had
already put those two perspectives into
dialogue with one another so so then
when they went for this this visual
experience they already had some
vocabulary they they already had a kind
of dialogic model in their minds and I
asked them to kind of preview questions
to think about before they went into the
VR and one was specifically what
features contribute toward the
monumental aspect of the throne room so
so getting them to think about the size
and the the monumental sculptures and
and we've been talking about
monumentality as as a cultural
expression since the beginning of the
course and the second question I asked
them was what features mark the space of
the throne room specifically as sacred
space and that's another concept that we
had been working with since the
beginning and so you know you saw some
of the the fires that that were there in
the room and and what the students one
of the things that they talked about in
there and their writing work their
written responses was that you could
almost smell the the incense burning in
in the brazzers and they talked about
specifically we you didn't have time to
look at it on the on the video that we
just saw but but some of the the very
detailed sculptures that are
incorporated into the larger
architectural plan of this room they
were prepared from that from previous
work that they had done so when those
were high light high lit in in the VR
and they they turned to look at it and
it kind of jumped out at them
they could plug that into the the
studies that they had already done so
what came back in the written responses
were much compared to previous years
when they had simply gone to the art
gallery much richer response
incorporating these different elements
within this space that was marked in
different visual and and sensory ways
and it allowed in addition to kind of
enriching their own appreciation of what
they were looking at in the written
response they were much more imaginative
they were much more creative in in in
the letters that they wrote back home
for their experience of having visited
the King and what what really came
through and again they were prepped for
this this came at the end of the
semester was the punchline of the course
which which is that this the figure of
the hero in in in ancient Near Eastern
culture is a figure that kind of
negotiates a lemon between you know the
the the limits of of human experience
and divine experience and and so this
throne room where they saw the king and
throned within this space that's marked
as being sacred in some ways but is
nonetheless a human-sized person because
he is a human being he's just kind of
you know held up on in a very particular
way as the focus of taking this very
long walk down a very long hall in a in
you know ceilings that are three stories
high but yet he's of a human dimension
so they got that and they wrote about
that in their written responses in in a
much more rich way
I think actually I I used technology
that I didn't go to the extremes that
some of these other presentations
represent at the same time Ida found
that I did have to do some training with
my students who were generally bookish
humanities students who don't create
websites and things like that and one of
the best conversations that came out of
that was talking about communication and
about the students as as cultural
ambassadors themselves and having them
think about what sort of publics they
want to reach with the new information
that they have acquired in an upper
level language class so we did talk
about that and we had trip visit the
class a couple of times to work through
just the technological the steps of
creating their their interventions but
also one of the parts of the website was
having them visualize their final papers
for the course and and I found that that
really helps them to consider their
arguments in new ways and they were
mapping out relationships between a
particular character and one novel in
another for example so um for games I
don't feel like we have really had to
teach the students like much about
gaming but more of like how to work in
groups on a case study so that usually
takes some effort I think and in helping
students figure out what do they need -
how do they need to work together as a
team etc um for the actual game itself I
guess the the one part of it and I you
know I don't show you the entire case
here but it's very scaffolded it gets
into a lot of detail of the biology and
then it inserts this game in a very
thoughtful deliberate way and so the
students have particular learning
outcomes that they're supposed to kind
of you know think about as they play the
game so I think that helps them - and
playing the game they're supposed to
look out for these things and then also
when we're designing the game we were
trying to think about how to engage
more than just playing it so we told
them okay well now you're gonna have to
manipulate change your genes change the
gene order and what does that do and how
does that relate to what you know so
just like those types of things I think
really helped them to at least engage
with the technology in a higher level of
like you know learning you know
something from it one other thing I'll
say I know we've got maybe the most
traditional implementation of gaming but
just so we lecture in a video style
followed by then their responses to
questions and a free response but we
find what we find is the the students
are thinking about how they're learning
as they're doing this so they say things
like well the the lecture didn't tell me
how to do this problem which is which is
interesting right because if I just
given a lecture and then ask them a
question they might not give me that
feedback and they may not might not
realize that they have to create some of
this stuff for themselves but now I can
engage with the conversation saying okay
someone can explain something you can be
asked to do something and there could be
you know things that need to happen in
between and that's okay and you have to
understand that all right thank you all
very much we're at time and so I'd like
you to join me in thanking our speakers
today
[Applause]
[Music]